We're going to do a very well-known experiment called the elephant's toothpaste.
We're using concentrated hydrogen peroxide. As you can see,
I'm going to put some of that in all five liter Chronicle. Um,
and then I'll explain the rest as we go.
There are lots of videos on YouTube of this already.
So we thought we'd explain or trying to explain why it's so spectacular.
And of course, sprayed filmed it in slow motion,
which allows you to see quite a lot of the detail as the ranch and develops.
The final ingredient to our reaction is a saturated solution of
potassium iodide. So this is what's going to make this reaction go.
So at this point, I think Neil,
you need to move that way because I'm going to very rapidly be going that way as
well. Once this has been added in, so are you ready? Three, two,
one.
The reaction is a reaction of hydrogen peroxide.
I've got rather a crude model here.
It is H2O to two hydrogens, two oxygens.
The key part about this molecule is that the bond between the two oxygens
is rather long and rather weak.
You may remember that when you break bones,
you have to put energy into a molecule.
And when you make bones, you get energy back.
The overall energy that you have from a reaction that's where the heat comes
out,
or you have to put heat in depends on the balance between the
energy needed to break the bones and the energy needed to make them.
So in this case,
the reaction is overall that two molecules of H2O
to form two molecules of water and one molecule of
[inaudible] and Oh two oxygen has a double bond between the two
oxygen atoms. So if you look at it overall,
all you have done is to break two single bonds and make one double
bond. Because in both of them, you have four O H bonds,
four here and four here. And usually,
and the key to this reaction is that two single bonds
need less energy to break them.
Then you get back when you form one double bond,
that is the double bond is more than twice as strong as two single bonds.
So you'll break into single bonds between oxygen atoms,
making one double bond between two oxygen atoms and getting energy
out. And this is what makes the reaction work.
Now like most reactions,
you need some energy to get it started because hydrogen peroxide does not
spontaneously fall apart at room temperature.
So in this reaction, in the demonstration,
you have hydrogen peroxide, a bit of soap to cause foam.
Little bit of soap is just going into there. Yeah, just,
just washing up liquid liquid detergent.
Sometimes people put in a bit of coloring,
so it looks a bit more dramatic the foam.
And then you have to drop in the catalyst,
which reduces the amount of energy needed to break the first few
bones.
The final ingredient to our reaction is a saturated solution of
potassium iodide.
There's a choice of different catalysts.
You can use Sam used potassium iodide.
The potassium is not important. It's the iodide itself,
which can lower the energy needed to break the bond.
And because all molecules at room temperature have a certain
amount of energy with the catalyst.
There is enough energy in the system to get the reaction started.
Now,
once the reaction starts each molecule that reacts gives that
some heat. So the temperature rises, chemical reactions go faster.
It's the temperature rise. So more molecules react,
more heat comes out and you get a runaway process.
So the reaction goes faster and faster and faster.
So what he's doing now is actually using the oxygen of the foam to keep that
splint lit.
If you look at the reaction products, oxygen is a gas.
So you've got a liquid that is producing a gas,
which has a much bigger volume than the liquid.
And also because of the reaction mixtures heating up,
you're also producing some steam. That's the vapor of water though.
The volume of steam is probably much less than the volume of the gas.
The material needs to expand because the gas is at room temperature.
So it expands. And by having soapy solution,
you can make a foam so people can actually see the gas expanding.
The reaction would work just as well without the soap,
but then you wouldn't see the oxygen coming out.
There is the second very important and totally physical
aspect of this reaction.
And that is that the reaction is done in a conical flask with sloping
sides, two relatively small diameter neck.
And you will see the same thing in mode, any of the demonstrations on YouTube.
So what happens is that as the foam rises,
because the tube is getting narrow,
the speed at which it goes up has to accelerate.
And so it comes out with really quite a high speed and shoots up into the
air. And of course, as you get the column of the foam going up,
there's nothing supporting it. So when it runs out of momentum,
gravity makes it collapse down again.
[Inaudible].
I was really excited to see the foam overcoming a little
camera at the side.
So now we can actually demonstrate that
this conical flask is important because Sam wanted to do the reaction in one of
our big test tubes are barking dog tubes, which have straight sides.
She thought it'd be really spectacular.
Neil thought it would be a waste of time. In fact, they were both wrong.
It was not bad, but not nearly as dramatic as in a conical flask.
Wow. All right. You're right. You were right.
The takeaway message of this demonstration is that the
underlying chemistry provides the energy to get the reaction
going, but you need the catalyst to set it off.
And then the buildup of heat and the conical flask gets it
to go with the real whoosh.
So next time when you see the elephant's toothpaste, think of the science,
not the clowning of the people who are doing it.
[Inaudible].